so we're gonna see how well you know
movie Saurez oh boy I do well I don't
actually are you ready okay I'm ready
even gonna be way too good at this love
nothing more
oh we're gonna be great at this game I
feel like all of these I'm gonna say is
Magic Mike I'm just gonna go with Brooke
to pop if it's someone old I'm not gonna
know well I know from the tattoo is the
rock what what gives away I'm a huge
wrestling fan saw him shirtless six days
ago this one might be the most
recognizable I know them hairs anywhere
you can tell by this left nipple that's
Zach Efron it's just like the vein
composition people have noticed from the
veins people have noticed from the vein
your movie star
yours not they do come only later it's a
superhero I don't know how many more
hints I could give use my favorite dude
in the world Oh booth Leigh that's Chris
Pratt
I might freaked out I don't know what
the hazards AB this one's a little
tricky Will Smith Alvin Klein um not
Kelly client heart oh yeah it's
definitely you I think that's definitely
her that is a before shot of Michael B
Jordan this is insane you know you're at
what are you do that supposed to be
Jordan or no